It's the final rally of one of the most
fiercely fought elections in Paraguay's
Short history of democracy and the South
American country's largest opposition
party is confident of capitalizing on a
wave of discontent against corruption
and soaring poverty
we need so many changes it would take me
till dawn to list them all we need
security and safety medicine everything
education is the most important thing
without it nobody can wake up and demand
their rights
after two failed attempts opposition
leader and presidential candidate
Ephraim Allegre seems confident he'll be
Third Time Lucky his campaign slogan is
a choice between the mafia or the nation
we are going to defeat the paraguayan
Pablo Escobar and we are going to launch
the real Paraguay the Paraguay of hard
work of the family of patriotism that's
our Paraguay who is the paraguayan Pablo
Escobar I asked
he is the Pablo Escobar of Paraguay and
his hand-picked candidate Santiago Pena
is El Chile Escobar's right-hand man
he's referring to former president
Horacio cartes one of Paraguay's
wealthiest and most powerful men who was
sanctioned by the U.S in January for
quote rampant corruption that undermines
Democratic institutions and alleged ties
to drug trafficking and Hezbollah
he is also the president of the Colorado
party that has dominated paraguayan
politics for seven decades and the
political patron of its current
candidate former Finance Minister
Santiago Pena
hopeful told me that his mentor who
denies the charges of corruption has the
right to defend himself but he also
insists he's his own man nobody can
claim that I'm not prepared to be
president nobody can claim that I don't
have the expertise on public policy and
nobody can point to myself that I have
any case of corruption during my service
in the public administration until
recently victory for the powerful
Colorado party was seen as a given but
not this time
has chosen a woman as his running mate a
first in Paraguay the opposition
candidate has a lot of advantages not
only does it seem to have a very solid
Coalition behind him but also for the
very first time in seven decades he
appears to have more money to bring out
this number of people by contrast the
U.S sanctions against the incumbent
party's leader has made it more
difficult for to access bank loans and
other funds
still the Colorado party has a long
track record of staying in power pulling
it off again is not out of the question
despite the odds
you see in human Al Jazeera Asuncion